seit dem jahr zur massen einwanderungs
initiative im februar dieses jahres
scheint in der schweiz alles möglich das
verhältnis zur europäischen union ist
radikal in frage gestellt die initianten
geben sich in höchstform und die
politische elite und weite teile der
bevölkerung sind verunsichert jedes eng
in diesem land oder liegt es schlicht im
europäischen trend wo sich ebenfalls
nationalismen breit machen diese fragen
diskutieren ich heute mit der
westschweizer journalistin und autorin
chance für sie ist die unabhängigkeit
der schweiz ein mythos und dem
deutschschweizer philosophen georg
kohler er findet dass der erfolg dieses
landes immer in seiner fähigkeit zum
aufbruch lag die kunst die schweiz seit
diesem jahr zu masseneinwanderung
initiative eine andere
verändern 20.000 wählerstimmen ein land
ich denke dieses land hatte schon vorher
zweifel hinsichtlich seiner beziehung
zur europäischen union
diese zweifel nutzten parteien aus die
unsere beziehung zur eu nicht so gut
kennen
wir haben 20.000 stimmen verloren die
nun unsere beziehung zur eu völlig
verändern
viele zufälle haben und sind diese
situation gebracht und schlechte
politische arbeit aber wie wir wissen
war das land schon vorher voller zweifel
das ist glaube ich alles was man dazu
sagen kann
kohler überrascht sie die entwicklung
jetzt seit dem 19 februar oder ist das
eine mentalität
glaube ich ist schon ein unterschied
weil jetzt die differenz sozusagen
zwischen den beiden schweizern
deutlicher denn je geworden ist und
es ist etwas ich würde auch sagen
endlich zum ausdruck gekommen was man
eigentlich schon lange erwarten muss die
haben schon lange gesagt das ist eine
art kulturkampf zwischen einer schweiz
die ja sozusagen auf sehr alte muster
und vor allem auch auf rückzug setzt und
eine andere schweiz die sich mehr oder
weniger öffnen will aber noch keine
klare linie hat das heißt der neue preis
schon ein wichtiges datum weil das was
sich lange vorbereitet hat jetzt endlich
zum konflikt gekommen ist und die finden
muss man jetzt austragen die differenz
die knappe differenz zwischen stimme
spielt bei ihnen beiden eine große rolle
sie sagen es kommt dieser konflikt
endlich zum ausdruck musste das sein
muss das wirklich soweit kommen
ja ich denke schon das hängt damit
zusammen dass
natürlich eine bestimmte nah wie sollen
wir das nennen
politische gegen elite also die svp man
kann das ja wirklich man muss es auch
personalisieren mit ihrem chef christoph
blocher das weite und
keinerlei
mindestens seit 56 jahren keinerlei
anstalten zeigte eine sozusagen
vermittlungs position zuzulassen in dem
moment als die eu klar machte dass es im
zusammenhang mit den sogenannten
institutionellen probleme
neue regelung braucht in dem moment war
klar
für christoph blocher ich muss das
verteidigt man sich die unabhängigkeit
die souveränität und anderes nannte also
es liegt daran dass es eine in dran
sinkende andere seite gibt aber okay das
ist politik
die frage ist ja es wird jetzt oft der
erfolg des populismus baut und noch
lauter eigentlich nach dem 94 mal dass
man da nach der stimme des volkes redet
dass man dieses volk verführt wie
schätzen sie das ein frau kunst ist
dieser vorwurf gerechtfertigt oder nicht
das ist populismus
populismus heißt dem volk zu gefallen
ist das schlecht ja und nein es hängt
davon ab was man dem volk sagt
ich würde eher von demagogie sprechen
mehr als dem volk gefallen will man es
verführen mit dingen die das volk
einfach findet die ihm gefallen und
schmeicheln to flatter
aber die demokratie ist meiner meinung
nach etwas sehr kompliziert ist sie
erfordert die fähigkeit abstrahieren zu
können und nicht die fähigkeit uns
glauben zu machen die erde sei flach
die erde ist nicht flach um sie zu
verstehen muss man sie studieren und
dinge abstrahieren können
ich glaube dass die demokratische
schweiz dank langfristigem bemühen mit
den bürgern ich spreche lieber von
bürgern als vom volk die fähigkeit
entwickeln konnte konzepte zu
verallgemeinern und zu abstrahieren
konzepte die uns zusammenhalten
nun treten plötzlich demagogen auf die
mit so einfachen dingen kommen wie das
die erde flach ist
die leute sind ein wenig erstaunt aber
viele haben keine zeit sich mit politik
zu befassen zeitungen zu lesen und
detailliert alle vorstöße zu studieren
die gemacht werden und sie glauben ihnen
wir sind also in einer situation in der
mit vereinfachungen und täuschung
operiert wird doch die heutige realität
der welt ist kompliziert
man sollte also fähig sein die
komplexität so gut wie möglich
aufzuzeigen
und mit den bürgern eine beziehung
aufzubauen die sie dazu ermuntert dinge
zu hinterfragen
zweifel zu äußern fragen zu stellen um
zu diskutieren
doch hier wird nicht diskutiert sondern
behauptet man operiert mit massiven
behauptungen in dem man komplexe
sachlagen vereinfacht und damit die
bürger verführt
so sehe ich das und das ist nicht
populismus sondern reine demagogie
das ist ein wenig ärgerlich für dieses
außergewöhnliche politische system dass
demokratie heißt und erfordert dass man
komplexität akzeptiert lag situation der
komplexität sie spielen sehr stark auf
die differenz zwischen populismus und
demagogie also der reihenfolge verfügung
an würden probieren sie denn die
differenz setzen sind sie mit dieser
differenzierung ein oder seien
populismus des werks auf tourismus ist
ja sozusagen populär geworden es ist ja
eine medikation die deutlich positiven
charakter hat
es ist sozusagen ein lateinisches
lehnwort demographie der demagogie ist
ein griechisches läden wort aber ich bin
völlig einverstanden mit dem was frau
und sagte ich würde höchstens noch einen
weiteren unterschied einbringen also auf
der einen seite ist demagogie eine
technik eben vereinfachung
also die schrecklichen vereinfachen
terrible sämtliche katar
und in einer welt wie heute ist das
immer schlecht aber auf der anderen
seite begreiflich weil wir ja aus
verschiedenen gründen auch
verunsicherungen erleben von großen
teilen der bevölkerung also der
schreckliche vereinfachen hat dann gute
chancen wenn er auf ein klima der
verunsicherung stößt kann sich fragen
woher das ist das ist aber der fall das
zweite ist sozusagen eine eine technik
eine rhetorische technik das zweite zum
populismus auch zur demagogie gehört
theorien nämlich die theorie dass es
freunde und feinde gibt und bis zu einem
gewissen grad auch die theorie dass erst
wenn wir einen ordentlichen feind haben
wir auch wissen wer wir sind und
das ist auch besonders gefährlich
natürlich gibt es situationen wo es nur
ein entweder-oder gibt
das hat man erlebt im zusammenhang mit
nazideutschland und so weiter aber
normalerweise ist es eben schlecht wenn
man in freund feind schema tief man
denkt aber sie kommen an und es ist
diese theorie
die ja nicht nur in der schweiz noch ein
bisschen gemäßigter ist der feind was
schlicht lächerlich ist das vierte reich
eu also es tut mir leid ich finde das
lächerlich aber sie hören andere sagten
gerade jetzt so von
demagogen in russland die sagen also der
westen zerstört unsere russische kultur
es ist also schon ein gemeiner
europäisches phänomen aber es gehört zur
politik der demagoge in einer bestimmten
situation hat mit vereinfachung plus
freund feind schema thiemen meistens
einen recht guten erfolg erfolgt muss ja
darin bestehen dass man da auch gerne
zuhört das ist genau das ab holt was man
eigentlich selber denkt also es heißt
zudem zur demagogie oder so ein
populismus ich auch immer gehört immer
auch ein volk das das annimmt
habe ich ihre frage richtig verstanden
das heißt das problem des demagogen ist
nicht nur desjenigen der demagogisch
spricht und das volk verführt sondern
auch es volkes das sich verführen lässt
dass diese vereinfachungen wie sie
genannt haben gerne annimmt und auch
gerne hört
grund ist dass das ist eine große
geschichte die frage nach der kompetenz
des volkes dieser kategorie die man als
volk bezeichnet seine fähigkeit zwischen
dem wort des demagogen und dem wort des
philosophen zu unterscheiden
ich denke etwas weiß man nun zumindest
seit den zwanzigsten jahrhundert das
volk lässt sich in eine meute verwandeln
es gibt einen großen unterschied
zwischen dem volk dass entscheidungen
fällt und dem volk das sich in einem
heute verwandelt eine meute die dem
führer folgt
das ist die große erfahrung des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts zumindest in
europa und auf diese erfahrung muss man
reagieren können
was mich beeindruckt an diesem konzept
von freund und feind dass sie sehr gut
dargestellt haben was ist mit jenen die
nicht in diese kategorie passen
das sind die politiker die informiert
und fähig sind mit komplexen dingen
umzugehen und sie lassen sich von diesem
freund feind konzept vereinnahmen ich
würde sogar sagen terrorisieren
was mich an der heutigen situation in
der schweiz beeindruckt ist weniger die
präsenz einer demagogischen partei
sondern vielmehr wie viel faszination
und einschüchterungen sie bei andern
auslösen kann
ein volk lässt sich einfach demagogie
sieren wenn keine alternative vorhanden
ist weil sich die anderen kräfte
zurückgezogen haben wo sie geld gebracht
sie sind also in der gesellschaft suchen
ihre stimme ihre leute und hören die
laute stimme der demagogen aber keine
anderen stimmen
sie wissen nicht ob es alternativen gibt
obwohl sie wissen dass die demagogische
partei nur über 30 prozent der stimmen
verfügt wo sind also die anderen was
sagen sie wie soll man damit umgehen
die mehrheit hat sich noch nicht
vollumfänglich von den demagogen
verführen lassen nur in momenten wie
solchen volksabstimmungen der die sich
davon blenden
diese nähmen jedoch zu denn für eine
partei die bei den wahlen nur 30 prozent
der wähler stimmen holen konnte ist es
faszinierend in einer initiative eine
mehrheit für sich zu gewinnen
wir sind alle wie von einem stern von
der idee angezogen bei einer
volksabstimmung 50 prozent der stimmen
gewinnen zu können
und jede volksabstimmung verstärkt diese
falsche idee dass die demagogische
populistische partei bereits gewonnen
hat
wir sind also in einem völlig
verworrenen system und haben keine klare
vorstellung von alternativen
in diesem zustand ist das volk wollen
sie 50 prozent gegen minarette gewinnen
nur zu man kann auch 60 prozent mit noch
protestieren vorstößen gewinnen
was frau kunz anspricht ist ja sozusagen
der der gegensatz zwischen den
populismus und dem philosophen könig
wenn wir mal ganz weit gehen aber quasi
der dem der fähigkeit zu differenzieren
in einer schwierigen welt und was ja
auch sagt ist die tatsache dass diese
differenzierung fast nicht mehr möglich
ist liegt das im wesen der demagogie
dass die finanzierung schwieriger wird
oder braucht es einfach mehr mut ja
stimme mehr klarheit ja also wir haben
zwei dinge glaube ich zu unterscheiden
das eine ebenso zu sagen die politische
rhetorik die voraussetzungen waren
demagogische techniken funktionieren
und dann ja die situation der schweiz
und jetzt muss ich doch ein bisschen
die partie da svp und ihrer anhänger
verteidigen
selbstverständlich da bin ich vollkommen
einverstanden sind es hier rhetorische
mittel die auch der magischen charakter
haben die eine rolle spielen aber
ich würde sagen in der jetzigen
situation ist es natürlich auch eine
ganz wichtige entscheidung die man zu
treffen hat zwischen einer schweiz wie
wir sie lange gekannt haben die
beispielsweise ja sagte wirtschaftlich
sind wir mit dem rest der welt vernetzt
aber politisch mit unserer nicht nur
demokratie sondern direkten demokratie
sind wir sozusagen auf einem anderen
stern unabhängigkeit und das müssen wir
zugeben wenn wir neben den bilateralen
weg fortsetzen dann wird das einbußen
für die direkte demokratie haben ich
glaube dass wie man so in der schweiz
sagt schleckt keine geiss weg wir müssen
zugeben dass diese errungenschaft hat
direkten demokratie tangiert wird und
insofern sind völlig mit ihnen
einverstanden ist sehr viele
elemente sehr demagogisch art die ich
gefährlich findet die sozusagen die
politische kultur der schweiz die auf
konsens und kooperation verständigung
zielt gefährden aber es ist schon eine
schicksalsfrage und bei schicksalsfragen
vor allem wenn das auch noch verknüpft
ist eben mit einer allgemeinen
unsicherheit die nicht nur eine
schweizerische sondern gesamteuropäisch
ist dann meine ich gibt es sozusagen
sehr ernstzunehmende probleme auf der
einen seite die dann wenn man geschickt
ist mit demagogischen mitteln auch noch
verschärft werden und das andere problem
ist dass aber da wollen wir nicht so
sehr die andere seite die nicht so klar
weiß was sie will die einfach sagt wir
müssen uns anpassen ist viel diffuser
das spielt auch diese anderen seite aber
das ist mir wichtig wir sind an einem
punkt in der schweiz sei eine
schicksalsfrage ist hier spielen
demagogische elemente leider eine rolle
aber ich finde man sollte auch sozusagen
die ernsthaften dinge auch sehr
ernsthaft also die philosophischen dinge
philosophisch diskutieren jetzt wenn wir
diese ernsthafte frage nehmen und sagen
die schweiz steht am scheideweg entweder
quasi gibt sie ihre direkte demokratie
preis und auch ein teil ihrer geschichte
oder nicht
aber wie schaffen wir es wissen wir es
zu dann nehmen wir doch ihr büchlein
ihren zwischenruf wie sie es nennen
schon kunst die schweiz oder die kunst
der abhängigkeit wo sie eigentlich
wirklich sagen die schweiz ist nicht
unabhängig sie beherrscht schlicht die
kunst der abhängigkeit also die ist
eigentlich gar nicht so an dass sie das
was er gesagt hat steht gar nicht so zur
debatte sondern war eigentlich gar nicht
so geben sie uns ein beispiel aus der
geschichte der schweiz und diese kunst
der abhängigkeit beherrscht wurde
ich würde sagen sie war von anfang an
also seit ihrer gründung 18 48 49 mit
der frage der flüchtlinge konfrontiert
die schweiz war das einzige land in dem
die demokratische revolution gewonnen
hatte 8 überall sonst scheiterte sie
deshalb war die schweiz mit vielen
politischen flüchtlingen konfrontiert
die sich bei uns im paradies finden weil
hier die demokratie erlaubt war und die
damalige liberale haltung war allen
diesen flüchtlingen schutz zu gewähren
da rundherum die monarchien gewonnen
hatten sahen sie unser land als
brutstätte der region um subversivität
und verlangten von der jungen
unabhängigen schweiz alle diese
flüchtlinge auszuweisen und sie an die
monarchien auszuliefern oder zumindest
nicht mehr als knotenpunkt für die
organisation der demokratischen
revolution zu dienen
die schweiz weigerte sich aber sie sagte
nein angesichts von militärischer
bedrohung
was hat sie also gemacht sie hat ihre
prinzipien erklärt und dargelegt wie sie
ihre unabhängigkeit ihrer souveränität
verstand doch gleichzeitig musste sie
sich der allgemeinen situation
unterordnen
dabei versuchte sie ihre würde zu wahren
aber sie ist schließlich auf die
forderungen der anderen eingegangen
sie konnte nicht einfach sagen das sind
unsere sitten da ist unsere fahne ihr
habt nichts zu sagen das konnte sie
nicht und ich glaube das wollte sie auch
gar nicht
denn die schweiz wie übrigens auch die
usa verstand ihre unabhängigkeit nicht
so dass sie sich von der restlichen welt
abschotten wollte
sie sah ihre unabhängigkeit als eine
neue art der verbindung sie ist keine
trennung sondern eine art der verbindung
mit neuen regeln
wir sind nicht allein aber wir wollen
uns als gemeinschaft verteidigen und das
von uns gewählte politische modell
verwirklichen aber wir sind mit euch
verbunden das ist der wichtigste punkt
der auch heute noch zutrifft die
unabhängigkeit ist keine abschottung
sondern eine verbindung die als solche
behandelt werden muss die unabhängigkeit
nicht als autonomie sondern aus
verbindungen zu anderen 1848 49 war es
die militärische bedrohung wenn wir das
noch heute übersetzen sind wir zwar noch
nicht gerade militärisch bedroht aber es
geht doch eigentlich um die zukunft
unseres landes
wie soll die schweiz heute reagieren in
dieser wo an welcher unabhängigkeit dann
welcher idee der unabhängigkeit soll sie
fest dran und ja zunächst mal an eben
das was schon kunst
ingenieur müller die bahn das nennt also
die kunst in abhängigkeiten zu überleben
also da gibt es ja viele varianten noch
wir wollen jetzt nicht das dritte reich
ja klar erklären aber da hat sich die
schweiz ja nun auch angepasst und
beispielsweise die berühmten volksrechte
wurden damals unter diesem regime
des zwangs zur anpassung ziemlich
ausgehebelt also da konnte man sich auch
damit abfinden offensichtlich und zu dem
was man in abhängigkeiten zuwandte nennt
man darf nicht vergessen dass die
schweiz
so stolz auf ihre bewaffnete neutralität
im grunde genommen während des ganzen
kalten krieges nichts anderes war nicht
militärtechnische militär politisch
waren wir ein trittbrettfahrer der nato
ich kann es nur noch mal sagen wenn man
von souveränität redet dann gibt es zwei
aspekte so entsteht nach außen nach
innen und nach außen hüter der eigenen
grenzen zu sein das waren wir schon aber
im verbund mit dem atlantik packt das
hat man verdrängt und in diesem sinne
meine ich ist die schweiz einfach
heutzutage
ja aufgerufen nicht sich aufzugeben das
ist ja einfach sozusagen auch eine böse
phantasmagorie wenn die schweiz über den
bilateralen weg sich irgendwo ein findet
in dieser europäische gesamtheit dann
geht es jedoch nicht unter wir sind viel
zu klar die die wir sind und wir müssen
gewisse zugeständnisse machten aber das
heißt nicht dass man die direkte
demokratie einfach aufgibt das ist ja
alles falsch wenn man es eben so sehr
vereinfacht und so gesehen ist es heute
eben besonders schwierig das
freund-feind-denken aufrechtzuerhalten
weil wir das nicht von mir aber das ist
so wir sind von freunden umzingelt es
ist einfach falsch mit an sagt die eu
ist das vierte reich es sind
freundschaftliche staaten die selber
auch souveräns in die mit uns einen ja
weg des gemeinsamen europäischen hauses
suchen und ich meine für die schweiz
kommt kein weit sie haben ja gefragt was
soll man machen kommt kein beitritt in
diesem sinne in frage aber es ist klar
man kann den bilateralen weg fortsetzen
und da hat natürlich christoph blocher
erreicht wenn man den bilateralen weg
weg fortsetzt dann bedeutet das nicht
einfach einen schleichenden beitritt
auch das ist eine demagogische
verkürzung es bedeutet eine gewisse
anpassung im rahmen dessen was schreit
kunst
die landebahn das nimmt aber bedeutet
diese anpassung jetzt wenn nicht eine
preisgabe der direkten demokratie dort
dann doch eine empfindliche schwächung
ihres den haben doch darüber noch gar
nicht gesprochen
man müsste darüber diskutieren
genau über die bedingungen und wie das
aussehen soll bei den gegenwärtigen
diskussionen geht es um das drama fremde
richter zu lassen zu müssen
das ist ein mythos nicht die realität
die schweiz muss viele geschäfte tätigen
die fremde richter betreffen
wir lieben in der welt wir tätigen
unzählige handelsgeschäfte es gibt das
internationale recht und manchmal
befassen sich schweizerische und
manchmal ausländische richter damit
und plötzlich david man uns vor wir
befinden uns noch im land von gessler
und versetzt uns in einen mythos zurück
der absurd ist
die eu ist ein juristischer raum und
wenn die schweiz in einem raum geschäfte
tätigen will denn nicht der eigene ist
muss sie akzeptieren dass europäische
richter über konflikte befinden die
daraus entstehen können
das scheint mir recht und billig aber
man beschwört diese figur des
europäischen richters herauf und solange
man sie nicht dämonisiert kann man die
realität unserer beziehungen mit der eu
nicht verstehen
genau der punkt dass wir eigentlich
jetzt mal ordentlich über diese fragen
die meinetwegen der einen kulturkampf
sie stellen diskutieren und sie nicht
dämonisieren mythologie sieren einfach
auf dinge reduzieren ja die sozusagen
alles oder nichts bedeuten
beispielsweise diese berühmte rechts
übernahme die nötig ist im zusammenhang
ein fass mit eben dem fortsetzen des
bilateralen wegs das ist ja rechts
übernahme im rahmen des
wirtschaftsrechts nicht im rahmen
sozusagen das zivilrecht die viele
prozesse wenn man sagt einfach fremde
richter rechts übernahme ende der
unabhängigkeit oder der souveränität
nein es sind in weitesten teil im grunde
genommen ja dinge die relativ klar zu
übernehmen sind die wir bisher immer im
so genannten autonomen nachvollzug
gemacht haben und die sehr vieles gar
nicht betreffen also wofür ich plädieren
würde ist einfach mal völlig mit ihnen
einverstanden zurück zur realität mal
schauen was da ist und natürlich auch
die gegenrechnung machen was bedeutet es
wenn wir uns abkoppeln
diese gegenrechnung dürfen wir auch mal
müssen wir auch machen und die hat auch
einige nachteile wenn wir das jetzt aber
noch mal runter auf den boden holen wer
muss wie zurück zur realität warum ist
es nicht möglich diesen diskurs sachlich
in der schweiz zu führen
wie sie gesagt haben ist die frage die
sich uns stellt sehr wichtig
es ist ein wendepunkt europa ist seit
dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs die
frage für uns schweizer
europa ist der absatzmarkt für die
schweiz
wir hatten immer schwierigkeiten mit
europa weil es sich im krieg befand
seit in europa frieden herrscht hat die
schweiz denke ich ein anderes problem
wie kann man mit der eu eine friedens
beziehung unterhalten die freund feind
diskussion die funktionierte als die
europäischen nationen gegeneinander
krieg führten funktioniert heute nicht
mehr jetzt muss man über die schweiz auf
einem friedlichen kontinent nachdenken
damit haben wir ein problem seit beginn
seither gab es eine entwicklung und nun
braucht es entscheidungen
daher sind die nerven von uns allen
gereizt
es herrscht eine große irritation
das ist ein guter punkt wer sind wir
haben nicht mehr die möglichkeit neutral
zu sein zwischen feinden sondern also
die situation ist wir sind von freunden
umzingelt
europa ist das land auf das wir
angewiesen sind mit dem er
freundschaftlich verbunden sind wo wir
auch sehr interessiert sein müssen dass
das funktioniert und das irritiert
sozusagen tief eingewurzelt
verhaltensweisen sie fragten ja und wo
wir diese diskussion geführt ja im volk
ich glaube sie wird stärker geführt
werden also wir beginnen sozusagen damit
natürlich meine wir haben eine
verschwindende minderheit die zuhört
aber selbstverständlich müssen alle
diejenigen die bisher sagten okay wir
halten uns aus der politik raus oder
alle die jungen die sagten ach als
langweilig und so weiter die müssen
mobilisiert werden nun nicht im sinne
natürlich hoffe ich in einer richtung
aber sie müssen primär mobilisiert
werden auf die frage und auf die
auseinandersetzung mit der frage hinwies
dass wichtig ich glaube aber das kommt
und das ist natürlich naja sie fragen
wer macht das ist die aufgabe der
parteien zum donnerwetter wer denn sonst
die parteien sind lego antrag media die
wichtig sind und die svp hat das schon
mal gemacht dafür bin ich ihr sogar
dankbar weil sie das problem aufs tapet
gebracht aber die freisinnigen die
sozialdemokraten die cvp umso weiter ich
sehe aber dass das kommt weil es nun
wirklich eine schicksalsfrage geworden
ist ist die perspektive und sagen das
ist die aufgabe der parteien in der
schweiz diese diesen diskurs zu führen
wir sind von freunden umzingelt jetzt
ist es ja aber so dass innerhalb dieser
freunde innerhalb europas ja ähnliche
parteien also dass ich da auch
nationalistische parteien
antieuropäische parteien eigentlich raum
verschaffen sie keinen frankreich besser
machen lippen information ahl spielt
ganz klar auf die karte gegen europa für
frankreich
und dann wäre nicht das selbe nicht die
selbe situation es ist nicht das
neutrale frankreich das sich einem
friedlichen europa gegenüber sieht sowas
ist ein anderes frankreich ist diese
situation mit der schweiz vergleichbar
das ist eine ganz andere
es ist ähnlich und gleichzeitig anders
ähnlich insofern als alle europäischen
staaten und vor allem frankreich auch
vor einer großen entscheidung stehen
als die europäische union entstand hatte
vor allem frankreich gegenüber
deutschland die haltung des siegers
während deutschland am boden lag und
sich neu aufbauen musste
es war die einigung zwischen einem
glücklichen frankreich und einem
hoffnungsvollen deutschland duisburg
deutschland war sehr erfolgreich und die
eu in gewisser hinsicht auch
frankreich ist nun an einem wendepunkt
wo es sich fragen muss ob es bereit ist
diesen weg weiter zu gehen denn dadurch
wird seine rolle abgeschwächt je größer
europa wird desto kleiner ist sein
einfluss auch frankreich steht also vor
einer existenziellen entscheidung auch
seine nerven sind gereizt
die gemäßigte sozialdemokratische und
rechte elite ist in frankreich so wenig
entschlossen und klar wie unsere sie
fragt sich machen wir weiter wie bisher
oder greifen wir auf nationale modelle
zurück
und ich würde sagen die versuchung einer
rückkehr zum nationalen modell ist umso
grösser als die wahlberechtigte
bevölkerung in der schule gelernt hat
dass das ideale siegreiche modell die
nation ist
im unterricht bahnen wird man auch heute
noch die gallischen kriege welche
frankreich gewonnen hat und beweint die
kriege die frankreich verloren hat
ideologisch sind eine noch dem
nationalen modell verhaftet auch die
bürger die wähler sie haben das in der
schule gelernt
in dieser situation wissen die politiker
dass sie ein anderes modell wählen
müssen aber ihre wälder hängen noch am
modell aus ihrer schulzeit sie sind also
nicht wirklich zu einem wandel bereit
und haben angst
wenn sie zudem nicht mehr verdienen als
chinesische arbeiter haben sie umso mehr
grund sich vor dem zu fürchten was die
globalisierung nennen
in allen europäischen staaten ist das so
aber vor allem in frankreich denn das
war der größte staat
dieses problem existiert also wir stehen
deshalb alle für diesen fragen die
faszinierend sind gehen wir in diese
richtung oder in eine andere
leidenschaft ist aber gefährlich aber
auch eben wirklich dieser scheideweg
dieser scheideweg war sie bleiben wir
eine nation oder lösen wir uns sozusagen
in europa auf ist dass die alternative
die sich hat sondern eben ist also
der nationalstaat ist eine
eigentliche erfindung des 19
jahrhunderts die nation bildet sich
heraus seit langem die nation dies auch
eine wenn man so wie die
sozialpsychologische erfindung aber der
grundsatz erwähnt war dann sehr
erfolgreich wollte auch ja ganz bewusst
strategisch sozusagen in die köpfe
gebracht in frankreich beispielsweise
und es ist ja nicht so dass es darum
geht
vereinigte staaten von europa ende der
nationalstaatlichkeit der der das
patrimoine der batterie sondern es geht
darum einen weg zu finden der eben neu
ist zwischen der notwendigkeit sich
transnational zu vernetzen und
gleichzeitig eben auch den pfeiler der
nationalstaatlichkeit zu erhalten das
ist eine schwierige sache das ist das
europäische problem und das problem was
dieses europäische probleme nicht den
gedanken fertig machen mit dem
schweizerischen verbindet ist die
demokratie in der tat
die tatsache ist die das hat der von mir
immer sehr geschätzt bei schwandorf ein
bedeutender europäer und liberale denker
immer sehr stark herausgehoben takt
demokratie ist bisher immer nur im
rahmen des nationalstaates gelungen und
die sozusagen ja idealform in
anführungszeichen der schweiz mit ihrer
direkten demokratie erst recht und
insofern ist dieses thema das wir vorhin
in der schweiz diskutiert haben
natürlich auch wichtig für europa und
europa ist genau auch an einer ganz
wichtigen phase aber also das ist
natürlich die ganz große sache wenn
europa insgesamt an dieser frage
gescheitert ist es auch für uns nicht
lustig doch im moment gehen wir nicht
noch nicht zu scheitern aber heißt das
denn dass wenn wir es nicht schaffen die
demokratie auf eine europäische ebene zu
heben dass die quasi den nationalstaat
in den nationalismus führt
die europäische demokratie ist nur
möglich wenn die demokratischen
eu-mitglieder sich bereiterklären
gewisse aufgaben abzugeben
doch wenn die nationalen demokratien
sagen dass sie die alleinige
souveränität haben und nicht darauf
verzichten ist niemand bereit eine
demokratie auf der höheren europäischen
ebene zuzulassen
das problem ist also das beharren auf
der nation dieser extremen nationalismus
der demokratischen mitglieder
es hat keinen sinn zu sagen die eu
funktioniert nicht weil sie nicht
demokratisch ist sie ist nicht
demokratisch weil die mitglieder sie
nicht demokratisieren weil die bürger
die demokratie ihres landes nicht in
einer übergeordneten europäischen
demokratie sehen
diese bewegung noch mal sagen wir
treiben wir die demokratie richtung
europa oder treibt sie uns in den
nationalismus ist das sozusagen die
alternative vor der wir und diese
umlegen entstehen also ich glaube muss
unterscheiden zwischen einer normativen
frage was wäre gut wie sein volk oder
eine gemeinschaft von menschen sich
organisieren sind wir alle der meinung
dass das demokratie ist auf welchem
niveau auch immer und den
notwendigkeiten die menschen in verbände
und in größere verbände bringen und am
ende ist es ja zunächst mal schlicht
eine funktionale notwendigkeit gewesen
dass europa entstanden ist man wollte
nicht mehr kriegt man hat deswegen viele
dinge die den krieg ermöglicht haben zum
beispiel damals die rüstungsindustrie
damit beginnt das jahr in den frühen
50er jahren
gemeinschaft und so weiter also es gibt
funktionale zwänge und diese
funktionalen zwänge erleben wir ja auch
jetzt die ich liebe wenn ich das noch
machen da ich lebe viele griechenland es
ist so dass letzten endes wenn man eine
abstimmung macht die griechen nicht aus
europa ausgeben wollen denn diese
europakritischen parteien an warum
wachsen die warum gewinnen die zuwachs
in dem sie sich gegen europa weil sie
sozusagen
nicht wirklich reinen wein einschenken
sie machten ein problem klar sie ja
sozusagen bewirtschaften
objektive missstände sie bewirtschaften
nicht objektive missstände sondern so
ein mulmiges gefühl
und damit gewinnt man vielleicht 30 40
stimmt wenn man aber bleiben wir beim
beispiel griechenland hat haas der die
linke an führt ja am himmels willen der
sagt man muss mit den europäern oder den
deutschen härter verhandeln und so
weiter aber er verträgt nicht austreten
aus der eu ich bin nicht einmal
überzeugt dass
marine le pen wirklich raus gehen wollte
sie spielt mit solchen missständen und
wenn wir deutschland nehmen jetzt die
etwas erfolgreicheren alternative für
deutschland sagt ja explizit wir sind
der meinung man müsste mit dem euro mit
dem euro an das verfahren aber gerade in
deutschland ist europa der europäische
zusammenhang kein thema wenn man fragen
würde europa und deutschland sich
trennen da bin ich überzeugt 80 prozent
der deutschen sagen nein spielt dir also
ist also können wir eigentlich in europa
keinen nationalismus keinen neuen
nationalistischen trend quasi festmachen
sondern ist es ein spiel um wie viel
souveränität wie viel nationale
souveränität wie viel europa ist es ein
natürlicher vorgang oder ist das eine
liegt darin eine sprengkapsel
die krise es kann eine kraft sein die
aus der krise erwächst es gibt kräfte
die mit dem nationalismus spielen es ist
ein spiel wir werden sie werden sehen ob
die schotten großbritannien verlassen
die spanier sind überhaupt nicht für die
unabhängigkeit von katalonien
interessant ist dass wir in einer welt
leben die sich mehr und mehr verbindet
eigentlich sind die positiven kräfte
verbindende kräfte
damit einher kommen gewisse
unannehmlichkeiten man muss gewisse
opfer bringen
deshalb versuchen die nationalisten in
die vergangenheit zurückzukehren
aber das ist vorbei
haben sie sich schon mal vorgestellt wie
es für frankreich griechenland oder
portugal wäre wenn sie wieder ihre
nationale währung hätten
man darf nicht vergessen dass wir den
euro geschaffen haben weil man alle
kombinationen und vereinbarungen
zwischen den verschiedenen währungen
ausprobierte und keine funktioniert hat
der euro war also die lösung für ein
problem das nicht anders gelöst werden
konnte das vergessen wir
genau jetzt bei dem bleiben sagen wir
man hat ja versucht europa über die
wirtschaftliche über den
wirtschaftlichen zusammenhang um
zusammenhalt sozusagen
zusammenhalts zu bringen und jetzt
rebelliert man gegen europa auch aus
politischer kultureller warte heißt das
auch dass die wirtschaft allein quasi
das nicht konnte kommt fordert man jetzt
etwas anderes und ist dieses ist diese
kulturelle komponente ist ja eigentlich
gefährlich oder ungefährlich
also grundsätzlich sind wir es von der
schweizer debatte in die europäische
gegangen und das heißt auch europa steht
an einem scheideweg und es gibt aus der
sozusagen entwicklung der evolution von
gesellschaften ja man kann es zwänge
oder notwendigkeiten nennen zu größeren
verbänden die die nationalstaatliche
einheit überschreiten früher um ein
beispiel zu sagen war der
wirtschaftliche markt war vom
politischen system sozusagen
eingemeindet eingemeindet heutzutage ist
es umgekehrt die märkte haben die
politischen systeme eingemeindet also
mehr oder weniger dominiert und mit zum
teil guten zum teil schlechten folgen
also man muss wieder sozusagen das
politische und das mag mäßige auf
dieselbe aufs selbe niveau bringen ganz
abgesehen davon leben wir ja in einer
welt wo wir große einheiten haben und da
sind sich alle einig die ein bisschen
einen kosmopolitischen blick haben aber
in europa und eigentlich sind wenn
europa eine chance haben will dann muss
es gemeinsame stimme haben
nicht einig sind die wollen ja genau
diese grenzen wieder stärken wir wollen
die zuwanderung quasi minimieren die
wollen die migrations kann man ja alles
machen also ich bin der meinung ich
verstehe durchaus
dass diese idee der offenen
grenzen in hinsicht auf alles mein
modell war dass man wieder anpassen kann
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt wenn
herr blocher sagt europa sei eine
fehlkonstruktion dann ist das deswegen
falsch weil europa nicht einfach eine
konstruktion sondern ein prozess ist und
im rahmen dieses prozesses werden dinge
ausprobiert werden aber auch dinge
wieder zurückgenommen wickelt sich etwas
und ich bin überzeugt natürlich in
verschiedenen schritten das ja die frage
wie geht man um zb in deutschland ist
das ein thema mit den sogenannten ja den
die die sozialsysteme missbrauchen die
halt auch aus irgendwie rumänien oder
bulgarien kommt auch das wird diskutiert
aber damit kann man ja umgehen es ist
nicht einfach ein entweder-oder dass es
scheitern muss oder nicht europa muss
gewisse dinge die in der schweiz die
schweiz ist auch ein bisschen ein labor
der europäischen probleme dass die
europäer auch dieser meinung bin ich von
den schweizerischen problemlagen lernen
können und ich bin überzeugt dass das
tun ist es deshalb dass die europäischen
anti europäischen parteien so gerne auf
die schweiz schauen und sagen die machen
das uns ja vor wie es eigentlich gehen
müsste
die anti europäischen parteien benutzen
die schweiz als nein sagen
die schweiz benutzt großbritannien als
das land welches das diktat aus brüssel
nicht akzeptiert
jeder versucht von dem was passiert zu
profitieren das ist eine politische
spielregeln aber
interessantes der prozess deshalb
versuche ich auch in meinem buch zu
erklären dass die schweiz erfolgreich
war weil sie sich auf einen prozess mit
den anderen eingelassen hat
es gibt wieder einen anfang noch ein
ende schon vor 1848 war die schweiz als
nation in einem entstehungsprozess es
ist ein langer prozess man kann nicht
genau sagen wann er begonnen hat man
kann sagen dass da oder dort eine
schlacht stattgefunden hat aber man weiß
nicht genau wissen
passion gemeinschaft die sich schweizer
eidgenossen nennen und diese bilden an
einem gewissen punkt einen start es
gelingt nur ihnen zu einem zeitpunkt wo
es viele andere auch anstreben
es ist also ein prozess dann haben wir
in der schweiz einen prozess der
relativen zentralisierung
im lauf der zeit hat man millimeter um
millimeter verhandelt um die
eigenständigkeit der kantone und um die
nationale eigenständigkeit
eigentlich wären wir für europa die
besten experten wir verstehen was
internationale verhandlungen in der
europäischen union mit sich bringen wir
haben diesen prozess durchgemacht und
gehen weiter nehmen wir nur genf und
lausanne ihre fusion wurde mit 80
prozent der stimmen abgelehnt aber wir
haben es versucht
nicht dass wir abgeblitzt sind sondern
dass wir es versucht haben und europa
versucht sich in vielen dingen wir sind
daran einen gemeinsamen frieden
auszuarbeiten kommune zu unterstreichen
sehr stark beide diesen prozessen
trotzdem möchte ich noch mal fragen wenn
wir diese diese doch sehr stark montiert
populistisch demagogisch agierenden
antieuropäischen parteien anschauen sind
die eine gefahr für europa
die jeweilige farbe ja sozusagen
theoretisch aber nicht praktisch ich bin
dafür dass die also wenn die schotten
was wahrscheinlich dann doch nicht
passiert sich unabhängig erklären würden
dann möchten sie so schnell wie möglich
wohin in die europäische union wenn man
mit kennern schottland england spricht
ist einer der gründe weswegen die
schotten mit dem englischen parlament so
nicht ganz zufrieden sind eben der dass
england so euro kritisch ist wenn
diese auseinandersetzung die auch also
politik besteht auseinander sind
auseinandersetzungen sofern bin ich
dankbar england mit europa ja wer ist
denn da gegenwehr wer die die city of
london und wovon is england abhängig von
dem finanzplatz es ist einfach falsch
wenn man behauptet dass europa
auseinander brechen ist griechenland ist
ein beispiel die spanier wollen drin
bleiben auch die deutschen das war ja
die idee von herrn mit er sozusagen die
deutsche ich weiß nicht atombombe
genannt d-mark zu minimieren indem man
den euro einführt leider ist es
umgekehrt herausgekommen deutschland
braucht den euro für seine
exportwirtschaft inzwischen ist das
alles ein grosser zusammenhang und euro
ist natürlich etwas ganz schwieriges
geworden aus vielerlei gründen aber
gerade der euro so kann man so
interpretiere ich ihn so kann man nicht
interpretieren ist auch ein projekt das
die südeuropäischen staaten bis zu einem
gewissen grade zu einem modernisierungs
gang nun ja zwingt aber so ist es also
es ist einfach falsch wenn man wirklich
behaupten also da meine ich das müsste
man empirisch recht leicht nachweisen
also wenn man behauptet europa steht vor
dem zerfall es ist schlicht falsch
denn wegen bogen zum anfang dieses
gespräch schlagen würde ich sie beide
fast so interpretieren und sagen diesen
parteien die europa so kritisch
betrachten ob in der schweiz oder in den
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten müssten
wir eigentlich dankbar sein weil sie uns
zwingen über dinge nachzudenken denen
wir eigentlich aber ausweichen
wenn sie nur die dinge auf den tisch
legen würden
findet eine debatte stand ich finde es
wird nicht genug diskutiert anders
gesagt die einschüchterungen sind zu
stark
in frankreich ist die sache mit marin
lippen ein drama sie löst keine
diskussionen aus sie provoziert unfälle
das gelingt ihr immer
aber frankreich diskutiert wegen ihr die
europäische frage nicht besser im
gegenteil
das ist die gefahr solcher parteien ihre
fähigkeit einzuschüchtern
und die amtierenden parteien während
sich nicht dagegen
in frankreich haben wir die situation
dass der präsident die regierung die
institutionen in der krise stecken weil
sie keine klare vorstellung der zukunft
haben und weil sie sich panisch vor den
nächsten wahlen fürchten
stichwort genannt man es kann unfälle
produzieren diese art politik zu machen
georg kohler in der schweiz
wenn selbst wenn wir dankbar sein müssen
dass diese fragen auf dem tisch steht
besteht die gefahr von unfällen nein
nicht traut den schweizern zu damit den
schweizern schweizer wind vielleicht
sogar noch mehr den schweizer wenn man
ehrlich gesagt
das hier ja
die debatte geführt wird und man sich
dann einfach ganz pragmatisch überlegt
was bringt und es bringt uns nichts so
ins abseits zuzugehen
also ich bin dafür man diskutiert welche
abstriche müssen wir institutionell
machen welche notwendigkeiten haben wir
wirtschaftlich und so weiter und wenn
wir diese rechnung machen und dann
daneben auch noch sehen dass europa ein
großartiges projekt ist es ist ein
großartiges projekt weil es den frieden
fördert und das ist nicht
selbstverständlich ist wenn man das mal
endlich auch sich sozusagen steigt das
es eigentlich eine fast verwirklichte
utopie ist dann
gewinnt die seite die den vernünftigen
weg weitergeht mit
55 zu 45 und das reicht das eine große
prognose blick nach frankreich und auch
europa wird europa diesen tendenzen
standhalten wird frankreich sozusagen
sich nicht einschüchtern lassen
wollen sie dass sich die zukunft
vorhersagen
machen sie eine vermutung
stellen sie eine vermutung an zu bluten
das ist wie verlangt
ich denke die geschichte ist voller
unfälle und
zufällig denn die hre zu folgender
aussage
ähnlich wie sie von der schweiz sagen
gibt es doch genügend europäer die für
europa einstehen und europa weiter
bringen
aber es braucht menschen die positiv
darüber reden
braucht träger dieser idee
sie können noch kommen warum nicht wir
sehen sie noch nicht aber niemand sagt
dass sie nicht auftauchen werden
es braucht gravierende abstimmungs und
fälle damit sich situationen ändern
ich finde man muss das ganze mit einem
rest von optimismus sehen
in der ukrainischen frage habe ich große
angst aber was den aufbau von europa
betrifft kann man einen gewissen
optimismus beibehalten
vorsichtig
bleiben bleiben wir dabei vorsichtig
optimistisch wenn kunst jörg köhler ich
danke ihnen beiden ganz herzlich für
dieses gespräch
nächste woche spreche ich in berlin mit
dem einflussreichen soziologen und
umstrittenen utopisten jeremy rifkin
auch da geht es wieder um große fragen
dieser zeit nämlich darum ob unser
gegenwärtiges wirtschaftssystem
demnächst vor einem anderen abgelöst
wird die zukunft ist offen wie bleiben
dran